les positions françaises sur le qui vive
avec la mort du président idriss deby au
pouvoir depuis plus de trois décennies
paris perd l'un de ses plus vieux alliés
et peut-être son plus important soutien
dans la région alors au milieu des
appels à une transition sans violence la
france n'oublie pas d'invoquer la
continuité dans la lutte anti jihadistes
aujourd'hui une transition commence dans
des conditions dont nous prenons acte
nous espérons qu'elle se déroulera
pacifiquement dans un esprit de dialogue
et de concertation pour aboutir à une
gouvernance civil stable et que la
transition militaire sera la plus brève
possible comme l'a rappelé récemment le
président de la république la lutte
contre le terrorisme au sahel ne
s'arrête pas et aux côtés de l'onu et
des forces du g5 sahel les militaires de
l'opération barkan continue le combat
contre les groupes armés terroristes
l'opération barkan un dispositif de
lutte contre les djihadistes mis en
place au sahel il y à 7 ans sur un
territoire presque aussi vaste que
l'union européenne
5000 militaires déployés cet avion de
chasse 20 hélicoptères 500 blindés pour
un total de près de 130 opérations de
combat jusqu'à présent le tout commandé
depuis cette base de commandement situé
dans la capitale du tchad n'djamena
l'un des trois seuls appui permanent au
sahel paris dispose également dans le
pays de deux bases avancées temporaire
dans le nord et l'est
autant de raisons pour les autorités
françaises de s'inquiéter le sujet du
tchad s'est aussi globalement la
sécurité du sahel et c'est aussi la
sécurité de l'europe
le tchad c'est un pays qui est au
carrefour de beaucoup de menaces
beaucoup de risques à la fois venant de
libye à la fois du nigeria
il faut être très vigilant à la fois sur
la stabilité de la situation aujourd'hui
est ce que le conseil militaire de
transition va assurer la stabilité
l'intégrité du tchad
et puis ensuite comment va-t-il pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre un processus
démocratique et comment par ailleurs
l'armée tchadienne va-t-elle remplir ses
engagements à l'égard de la force
conjointe du sahel il faut dire que la
solide alliance entre paris et n'djamena
tenait notamment au rôle de la france
dans la prise de pouvoir d'idriss deby
en 1990 appuyé par la direction générale
de la sécurité extérieure
la dgse la france qui a d'ailleurs en
retour raciste et son allié tchadien
dans ses combats contre les rebelles
venus de libye voici peut-être ce qui
explique les réticences de paris a
commenté l'arrivée de mahamat débit aux
affaires